Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at material parameter collections,
otherwise known as NPCs.
So what is an NPC, that is a material parameter collection, it is basically a system that
is used to control whole parameters of items in a material all at one time.
And it allows you to do sweeping changes such as maybe making decaying flowers as the
time in the day changes, or to make it rain, which I'll demonstrate in just a second here.
It can be loaded in sequencer and animated also for a sweeping control.
So you can even load it in actually call upon it via blueprints.
So you can use blueprints to control it, as in if you had a game scenario that you
needed to have some something happen a triggered event.
Or you can have it within sequencer when you're key framing it.
So those changes happen when and where you want them to.
So let's jump into Unreal and take a look at this up close.
So here we are in Unreal.
And if you see our scene, it looks pretty simple.
If you're wondering which scene do I have open, just simply go to our class folder,
go to maps, and you'll see the same icon here called NPC mat.
This is demonstrating how to use this particular note.
So if you simply click in the space, and the screen, you'll see that there is something
moving in there.
And that would be the rain.
And right now it's active and moving, but the opacity is gone.
So you won't actually see it in scene, because it's ready to be triggered, whether
it's via blueprint, or whether it's via a sequencer.
And I have this set up in sequencer.
So let's actually take a look at it.
So we'll go to cinematics for a moment, we're going to click on the simple animation
NPC.
Let's open that up.
Now as you open this up, you're going to notice that in here, we have some keyframes.
And we have some key things loaded.
What I simply did was go in here and add the material that I needed, you can drag it
in here if you need to, or you can add a material parameter collection here.
And this is the most simplest way to do it.
And then you can pick what you want.
I'm simply just clicking on the Add plus button here in sequencer.
In here, I can control these variables.
And what happens is, if I hit the keyframes here, you'll see that it gradually changes
from raining, and a very wet environment, and with a few splashes, hitting some of
the statue parts, and so forth, just for fun.
Now I can drag that back, and you can see it gradually change back to normal.
And you can do this with a lot of weather effects, whether it's like dirt over time,
or whether it's snowing and the snow builds up.
It's up to you how you want to do it.
But let me show you how this is actually built.
So if we go to our content drawer for a moment, we're going to go back to our in
class folder here.
And we're going to go ahead and take a look at the NPCs.
Now, we have an NPC folder in class that we can play with, you can feel free to
mess with some of this.
So I would literally just right click in here, go to materials, and you'll see material
parameter collection.
In the material parameter collection, we can call this NPC demo.
And you can do new if you want to make it distinguish from anything else you might be
playing with.
And I can double click on this, and it's going to open up into a new scene.
Now this window comes in here with two parameters ready to be slotted or created.
One is a scalar parameter like you normally would make with a material.
So if I hit plus here, I could call this and the control of, let's say, wet mess.
And then the value is set to whatever I want to key.
Now you got to be careful when you are in sequence, I'm going to pull this side just
for a second, that you can go beyond the range and you can kind of break your effect.
So just try to keep it within that zero to a more positive number.
So zero being off, and any positive number being on.
And that's really up to you.
In my particular case, one set of numbers takes it in your opposite direction, while
the other one you'll see here, that one for global roughness is its resting state.
But when I go over here and pull it up just because of the type material, you know
that roughness and metallic, they all kind of go kind of oppose each other in a way
on when it comes to their zero into one.
So that's really all that logic is in there.
So you can see that switch to a 0.3 and 0.2 for roughness there.
And you'll see the witness intensity a little bit more on the spec spectrum is a little
bit different here.
Okay, so in that can be plugged into your metal if you needed to.
So that's kind of how that logic works.
So just keep those things in mind.
And we can do vector parameters.
So this is if I wanted to change the color, I can put a plus on this one.
And I've added it in here and I can choose what I want, maybe it's albedo intensity,
or a betel color, and then intensity will be controlled up here.
And this could be the color information, if I wanted to, all of a sudden, make the walls
blood red, I can do so.
So this value is available also to be plugged in, we're mainly going to be living here
with a scalar primer, so you kind of get the point a little bit easier here.
Now one of the items we'll look at or pick on in the scene is this statue, because
he has several different NPCs in play.
So and what I mean by several, some of them are just being copied, but the different
aspects of the NPC can be active and slotted into different areas.
So if I double click on this material, we're going to go and bring this material up into
our screen, you'll see that I have a global high, global roughness, low, and a wet intensity.
And you're probably wondering, well, heck Sean, how did you do that?
Well, once you make your NPC, we can find where it lives, you can simply go in here
and drag it into your scene.
So I can drag this in here.
Now initially, it doesn't know what I want.
So I have to choose the parameter that I want to open up.
And in this case, I can choose wetness.
And there, what this is available.
And in that is a scalar parameter.
And that's kind of what we did here.
We're using global roughness high.
And in here, I'm choosing global roughness high, which has already been created within
that NPC, and I'm choosing that one to be our control for our roughness.
And I choose what its initial state is going to be.
And I can do that via sequencer or in the material itself.
It depends what you want to do.
In this particular case, you can see there's a texture here, we can change the swap that
out with something else, if we needed to.
And again, this is really up to you how you want to control these things.
And this is a pretty generic setup that I have here.
You'll notice I have a roughness low and a wet intensity in a multiply connected to the
specular to push things a bit farther.
If I wanted to, I could also connect things into a metallic if I needed to.
Now again, these are parameters that can be controlled.
And you're able to control exactly the look and feel that you want.
Heck, we can even have it so we have the normal increase in some way.
And we can use that vector that is open within the material itself.
And the reason these two are stacked upon each other, you're able to fluctuate between
each one of these, which vector you want to play with, and they're multiplying each
other, making magnifying each other.
So again, you don't necessarily have to do it this way.
But this is one way.
Let me show you the rock here.
In this case, which is a little bit more simplified, you can go directly into the
roughness and just have it work as a scalar parameter, as if I went in here and I simply
right click one of these and promoted it to a parameter, that's up to you, it's equal
to this roughness here.
So that's really all you need to do.
And they act as a sweeping control, because I can use this via I can call upon them
via a blueprint, or I can call upon them via my sequencer.
It's pretty great to be able to work with these and to be able to control them.
And you'll see the ground also has its own material.
If we go to the ground, let's double click on that ground, get that to pop up, pull this
over.
And you can see the same type of look and feel I have here, where we have a multiply
in here.
And if I wanted to, I can control that if I needed, or I can control that or keep
it pretty simplified.
So we're going into our lerps here.
And there's an alpha, which has a texture value or repeating, look and feel that I
want.
And I have texture coordinates in here.
This is all up to me how I want to do now it does look like a noodle fest.
But remember, at any time, you are not limited, you can do a named reroute node.
We're pretty notorious to have lots of noodles, as you saw within that motion design material.
But there's nothing that can keep you from using reroute nodes when you need it.
This is just something I've used for a while.
And it's been in place for a bit.
And you can definitely cater this to whatever you want inside of your system.
And again, you'll see down here, we have wet intensity, there's a divide, if I wanted
to put a scaler in here, to control things a little bit more, I totally can.
It's really up to you.
And you'll see that these work really well within the system.
So now when I hit play, again, it begins to rain, the embassy is active and things
look soaking wet everywhere.
Pretty cool.
And it's again, all up to you how you want to bring these to come about how you want
to play with these factors, and these elements, and you literally can just plug them in as
scaler parameters.
But now those scaler parameters are sweeping all across and can even be connected to certain
items to really get the effect and look that you feel and want in your scene.
That's about it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to look at some more complicated materials, such as
a parallaxed material, as well as subsurface in detail.
Thanks again.